good morning heck it's Tuesday I had
this whole video planned about trying to
become a Pinterest celebrity but I just
have to tell you the story of how
thousands of people just had the most
amazing feeling I'm friendly with a
fella named Ryan Reynolds who's a lovely
guy he supports the project for awesome
and lots of other stuff in this
community he's also a successful actor
and with his friend Rob he owns a
football club in Wales called wrexham
AFC he's also like part owner of a bunch
of different companies this guy Ryan
he's a real Hank Green when it comes to
jobs so listen I know that sports are
not very important like it is not
critical to the future of humanity
whether a ball goes over a line or into
a cup or through a net and I am
sympathetic to people who feel like
maybe we shouldn't devote hundreds of
billions of dollars in gobs of human
attention to the exploits of these balls
and the people who were paid to
manipulate them but I love sports not
for the lines or for the balls but for
the people for the way loving something
together allows us to feel Earnest
unironic connection and emotion in a way
I just couldn't feel otherwise also at
least among the best sports fans there's
an awareness that in sports as well as
in life no condition is permanent like
years ago I watched AFC Wimbledon the
team that we've sponsored for over a
decade that we're a dftba on their
shorts win a massive playoff final
against Plymouth Argyle and after the
game I saw this young man who was crying
green and white tears through his face
paint and I said I'm so sorry and he
said thanks great day for you lot though
in Sports One team's Joy is usually
another team's heartbreak but neither
the Heartbreak nor the Joy are Final in
fact Plymouth Argyle have been promoted
two times since that playoff final and
each time I've thought great day for you
lot but right about promotion in England
and Wales there are four tiers of
full-time profession football that's
called the football league and each
season the best and worse teams get
promoted up or relegated down among
these divisions but below the football
league is the fifth tier the national
league the league from hell because
there's only two promotion spots one for
the team that wins the league and the
other for the team that wins the
playoffs like Wimbledon escaped the
National League in 2011 thanks to two
brilliant saves from 19 year old Seb
Brown and we still sing about it every
single game so that's where reximar the
team owned by Rob and Ryan and in the
last 20 years that club has been through
hell they've lost out on promotion
through the playoffs five separate times
they went bankrupt fans had to pool
their savings to save the club and their
famously rollicking stadium and now they
are locked in an epic title race with
another great football club Knotts
County and yesterday they played each
other in a game that might just decide
who wins the title and it was just a
brilliant game I mean it's fifth year
football not all the passes are going to
be completed but the guts the heart the
noise of the fans the passion it was
just just incredible and then in the
final minute it was 3-2 rexham and
rexham gave up a penalty all season long
they've been lifted by their great
goalkeeper Rob Layton but he is injured
so rexham brought 40 year old Ben Foster
out of retirement so here's Ben Foster
playing in like his fourth game for
rexham after being retired for a whole
year the Knotts County player steps up
to take the penalty Foster Dives to his
right and saves it and the game ends
seconds later with wrexham fans in
absolute unadulterated Joy if rexham go
on to win the league they're going to
remember that day for a long long time I
know because of how long we've been
remembering Seb Brown saves they'll sing
about this day about 40 year old retiree
Ben Foster who sent them back into the
football league but then it wasn't just
Ben Foster was it it was also the other
players the coaches the owners the
groundskeepers and it was the fans who
made that place a cauldron of noise and
who held it together when it was falling
apart rexham gave each other that memory
and that is precise what will make it
last so long and burn so bright Hank
I'll see you on Friday